Voy a presentar tres proyectos muy rápidamente.
No tengo mucho tiempo para hacerlo
y quiero reforzar tres ideas con esa presentación acelerada.
La primera es lo que me gusta llamar un proceso hiperracional.
Es un proceso que
lleva la racionalidad a un nivel casi absurdo
y trasciende la carga adicional
que normalmente viene con
lo que la gente llamaría una conclusión racional de algo.
Y termina en algo que, vemos aquí,
algo que uno realmente no esperaría sea
el resultado de la racionalidad.
La segunda idea -- [poco claro] eh --
la segunda es que el proceso
no lleva firma.
No hay autoría. Los arquitectos se obsesionan con la autoría.
Esto es algo que tiene revisiones y un equipo.
De hecho, ya no vemos dentro de este proceso
al maestro de arquitectos tradicional que crea
un boceto para que luego sus lacayos lo lleven a cabo.
Y la tercera es que pone en tela de juicio – es
muy difícil sostener el por qué
todas estas cosas se conectan--
pero cuestiona la noción modernista de flexibilidad.
Los modernistas dicen: crearemos
espacios singulares que sean genéricos.
Dentro de ellos casi todo puede suceder.
A esto lo llamo flexibilidad tipo escopeta.
Giren la cabeza así, disparen, y seguro que aciertan.
Así, esta es la promesa del alto modernismo:
dentro de un espacio simple puede suceder cualquier clase de actividad.
Pero como vemos
los costos operativos están empezando a disminuir los costos de instalación
en términos de los parámetros de diseño.
Y entonces, con este tipo de ideas,
sucede que, sin importar lo que esté en el edificio el día de la inauguración,
o lo que parezca ser la necesidad más inmediata,
comienza a disminuir la posibilidad y como que se deja de lado,
la posibilidad de que pueda suceder alguna otra cosa.
Por eso estamos proponiendo una clase diferente de flexibilidad,
algo que llamamos
"flexibilidad compartimentada".
Y la idea es que uno, dentro de ese continuo,
identifique una serie de puntos y diseñe específicamente para ellos.
Estos puntos pueden alejarse un poco del centro
pero al final uno todavía conserva mucho
de ese espectro que originalmente había esperado.
En verdad, esto no funciona con la alta flexibilidad modernista.
Ahora voy a hablar de – voy a construir la Biblioteca Central de Seattle
de esta manera frente a ustedes en cinco o seis diagramas
y quiero decirles que éste es el proceso que van a ver.
Tanto con el personal de la biblioteca como con su junta directiva,
acordamos dos puntos clave.
Este es el primero: muestra la evolución del libro y
otras tecnologías durante los últimos 900 años.
Este diagrama fue nuestro posicionamiento respecto del libro;
nuestra postura fue que los libros son tecnología
esto es algo que la gente olvida --
pero es una forma de tecnología que tendrá que compartir su predominancia
con otros medios o tecnologías muy dominantes.
La segunda premisa -- y nos costó mucho
convencer a los bibliotecarios de esto al principio
es que las bibliotecas, desde el comienzo
de la tradición de la Biblioteca Carnegie en EE.UU.
tuvieron una segunda responsabilidad, un rol social.
Bien, voy a volver sobre esto después, pero algo
que decían los bibliotecarios al principio: "No, esa no es nuestra misión".
“Nuestra misión son los medios y, en particular, los libros".
De modo que lo que están viendo ahora es, en realidad, el diseño del edificio.
El diagrama de la parte superior
es lo que hemos visto en una multitud de bibliotecas contemporáneas
que utilizan alta flexibilidad modernista.
Una suerte de: cualquier actividad puede ocurrir en cualquier lugar.
Desconocemos el futuro de la biblioteca, desconocemos el futuro del libro,
por eso usamos este enfoque.
Y lo que vimos fue una serie de edificios muy genéricos.
Y, aún peor, no sólo vimos edificios muy genéricos
así, el salón de lectura no sólo se parece a la sala de fotocopiado
y ésta a la hemeroteca --
sino que esto significaba que cualquier tema que
aquejaba a la biblioteca en ese momento era
sumido en otra actividad que estuviese ocurriendo.
Y en este caso, eran obviadas
estas responsabilidades sociales como consecuencia de la expansión del libro.
Y entonces propusimos lo que aparece en el diagrama de la parte inferior.
Un enfoque muy tonto:
simplemente compartimentar. Colocar aquellas cosas cuya evolución podíamos predecir --
y con esto no quiero decir que podríamos predecir el futuro
pero sí que tenemos alguna certeza del espectro
de cosas que podrían suceder en el futuro
colocarlas en cajas diseñadas específicamente para eso
y poner las cosas que no podemos predecir en el techo.
Así que este fue el meollo de la cuestión.
Ahora, teníamos que convencer a la biblioteca de que el rol social
era algo tan importante como los medios
para lograr que ellos acepten esto.
Lo que vemos aquí es en realidad su programa, a la izquierda.
Esto es lo que nos dieron en toda su claridad y esplendor.
Lo primero que hicimos fue darles nuestra opinión luego de digerirlo,
mostrárselo y decirles:
"¿Saben qué? No lo hemos tocado
pero sólo un tercio del programa está dedicado a los medios y a los libros.
Dos tercios ya está dedicado -- esa es la banda blanca de abajo --
a lo que dijeron que no es importante:
ya está dedicado a funciones sociales".
Así, una vez que se lo presentamos nuevamente,
estuvieron de acuerdo en que esta especie de concepto “core” podría funcionar.
Teníamos el derecho de volver a los primeros principios
ese es el tercer diagrama. Recombinamos todo.
Y entonces comenzamos a tomar nuevas decisiones.
Lo que vemos a la derecha es el diseño de la biblioteca,
específicamente, en términos de metraje.
A la izquierda de ese diagrama, aquí,
verán
una serie de cinco plataformas --
especie de peines; programas colectivos.
Y a la derecha están los espacios más indeterminados,
como las salas de lectura, cuya evolución
en 20, 30, 40 años no podemos predecir.
Entonces, ese fue literalmente el diseño del edificio.
Ellos lo firmaron, y para su disgusto,
volvimos una semana después y les presentamos esto.
¿Correcto? Y como pueden ver, es literalmente el diagrama de la derecha.
¿De acuerdo? Simplemente los dimensionamos
no, de verdad, literalmente.
Las cosas de la – las de la izquierda del diagrama,
esas son las cajas.
Los dimensionamos en cinco compartimentos.
Son súper eficientes. Contábamos con un presupuesto muy limitado.
Los impusimos en el sitio para establecer
relaciones contextuales muy literales.
La sala de lectura debería ver el agua.
La entrada principal debería tener una plaza pública en frente
para acatar el código de urbanización, y cosas por el estilo.
Entonces, vean las cinco plataformas --
esas son las cajas – en cada una sólo ocurre una cosa muy discreta.
El área de entremedio es una especie de continuo urbano,
esas cosas cuya evolución no podemos predecir en el mismo grado.
Para darles una noción del poder de esta idea:
el bloque más grande es lo que llamamos la espiral de libros.
Se construyó, literalmente, de una manera muy económica
es un garage para libros.
Da la casualidad que está entre los pisos seis y diez del edificio
pero eso no es necesariamente un enfoque costoso.
Nos permitió organizar todo el sistema decimal de Dewey en una secuencia continua:
sin importar como crezca o se contraiga dentro del edificio
siempre tendrá su claridad
para finalizar esa especie de sendero de lágrimas
que todos hemos experimentado en las bibliotecas públicas.
(Risas)
Esta fue la operación final que consistió en tomar estos bloques
que estaban desordenados
y retenerlos con un revestimiento.
Este revestimiento cumple una doble función, por consideraciones económicas.
Una es la estabilidad lateral del edificio en su conjunto:
es un elemento estructural. Pero sus dimensiones fueron diseñadas no sólo para la estructura
sino también para sostener los vidrios.
El vidrio fue entonces --simplemente usaré la palabra impregnado --
tenía una capa de metal que llamamos metal estresado.
Este metal actúa como una micro persiana
de modo que desde el exterior del edificio el sol lo ve como totalmente opaco
pero desde el interior es totalmente transparente.
Bueno, ahora los voy a llevar a dar una vuelta por el edificio.
Déjenme ver si puedo encontrarlo. Para los que sean
sensibles al movimiento, pido disculpas.
Entonces, este es el edificio.
Creo que lo importante fue que cuando mostramos el edificio
por primera vez el público pensó que – lo vio como si se tratara de
un capricho, de nuestro ego.
Y fue defendido, créase o no, por los bibliotecarios. Ellos dijeron:
"Miren, no sabemos qué es, pero lo que sabemos es que todo lo que necesitamos está
basado en las observaciones
que hicimos sobre el programa".
Esto va en una de las entradas.
Es un edificio inusual para una biblioteca pública.
obviamente.
Ahora estamos entrando a lo que llamamos la sala de lectura -- disculpen, la sala de estar.
Este es, en verdad, un programa que inventamos con la biblioteca.
Fue reconocer que las bibliotecas públicas
constituyen el último vestigio de espacio público gratuito.
Existen muchos centros comerciales que nos permiten refugiarnos de la lluvia
en el centro de Seattle
pero no hay tantos
lugares gratuitos que nos permitan refugiarnos de la lluvia.
Ésta era un área no programada donde la gente podía hacer cualquier cosa,
entre ellas: comer, vociferar, jugar al ajedrez, etc.
Ahora subimos a
la que denominamos la cámara de mezcla.
Ese era, digamos, el área principal de tecnología del edificio.
Díganme si voy muy rápido.
Ahora hacia arriba.
Este es el lugar que pusimos en el edificio
para que yo propusiera matrimonio a mi mujer. Justo ahí.
(Risas)
Ella dijo que sí.
Me estoy quedando sin tiempo así que voy a terminar.
Puedo mostrarles esto más tarde.
Pero veamos si puedo entrar rápidamente a la espiral de libros
porque, pienso, como dije, que es la parte más --
esta es la sala principal de lectura – la parte más singular del edificio.
¿Ya están mareados?
OK, entonces aquí, esta es la espiral de libros.
Bien, es bastante irreconocible
pero en realidad es una escalera continua.
Permite, en una manzana,
subir un piso completo de modo que es una continuidad.
Bien, ahora voy a ir hacia atrás y así llegaré a un segundo proyecto.
Voy a ir muy, muy rápido.
Este es el Teatro Dallas. Fue un cliente inusual para nosotros
porque vinieron y nos dijeron:
"Necesitamos que hagan un nuevo edificio. Hemos estado trabajando en
un espacio provisorio durante 30 años
razón por la cual
nos hemos convertido en una compañía teatral de reputación.
La actividad teatral está concentrada en Nueva York, Chicago y Seattle
con la excepción de la Compañía Teatral de Dallas".
Y el hecho de trabajar en un espacio provisorio
significaba en realidad que para Beckett podían quitar una pared;
podían representar "El jardín de los cerezos” y cavar un pozo en el piso y cosas por el estilo.
De manera que construir un edificio de estas características fue una tarea muy intimidante;
un edificio capaz de albergar -- un edificio prístino
pero capaz de albergar ese tipo de naturaleza experimental.
Lo segundo es que ellos eran lo que llamamos
un teatro multiforme: ellos tienen
distintas clases de representaciones en el repertorio.
Así, por la mañana hacen
algo en un teatro circular,
luego algo en el proscenio, y así siguen.
Por eso necesitaban adaptarse rápidamente
a diferentes disposiciones teatrales;
y por cuestiones presupuestarias operativas
esto, en verdad, ya casi no ocurre en
ningún teatro multiforme de los Estados Unidos
de modo que teníamos que encontrar la manera de resolverlo.
Así, nuestra idea fue literalmente poner el teatro de cabeza:
tomar aquellas cosas definidas previamente como frente al escenario y detrás del escenario
y apilarlas -- arriba y abajo --
y crear lo que comenzamos a llamar la máquina teatral.
Invertimos el dinero en el funcionamiento del edificio.
Es como si el edificio pudiera ubicarse en cualquier lado: dondequiera que uno lo ponga, el área de abajo
está lista para representaciones teatrales.
Y esto nos permite volver a los primeros principios
y redefinir la torre escénica, la persiana acústica,
el sistema de iluminación, etc.
Y con sólo pulsar un botón el director artístico
puede cambiar escenarios: proscenio, teatro abierto y, de hecho,
arena y de piso llano
en transfiguraciones muy rápidas.
De manera que, usando presupuesto operativo podemos --
disculpen, gasto de instalación -- podemos lograr
en realidad lo que ya no era posible mediante costo operativo.
Y esto significa que el director artístico ahora cuenta
con una paleta que le permite escoger
entre una serie de formas y procesiones
dado que lo que rodea al teatro
generalmente atrapado en espacios frontales y traseros,
ese espacio ha sido liberado.
Por lo tanto un director artístico puede mostrar --
ejecutar una representación en la que ingresa una procesión wagneriana,
muestra el primer acto en un escenario abierto,
el entreacto en una procesión griega,
el segundo acto en arena, y así.
Bueno, les voy a mostrar qué – qué significa esto realmente.
Este es el teatro de cerca.
Cada parte del teatro puede ser abierta individualmente.
El sistema de luces se puede levantar en forma separada
de la persiana acústica, y así se puede representar Beckett
con Dallas como telón de fondo.
Se pueden abrir porciones y así permitir el ingreso de motocicletas
a la representación o, incluso, ejecutar una representación al aire libre
o para los entreactos.
Todo el anfiteatro se mueve entre esas configuraciones
pero también puede desaparecer.
La línea de proscenio también puede desaparecer.
Se pueden ingresar objetos enormes, de hecho
el primer espectáculo de la Compañía Teatral de Dallas
será una obra sobre Charles Lindbergh
y quieren traer un avión de verdad.
Y luego, en la temporada baja,
pueden alquilar el espacio
para actividades completamente diferentes.
Esto es de noche – lo siento, desde una distancia.
Abren porciones enteras para diferentes clases de eventos.
Y de noche.
Nuevamente, suprimen las luces; mantienen la persiana acústica.
Este es un espectáculo de camiones monstruo.
Ahora les voy a mostrar el último proyecto.
Este también es un cliente poco habitual.
Ellos invirtieron completamente la idea de desarrollo inmobiliario.
Vinieron y dijeron -- a diferencia de los desarrolladores tradicionales --
dijeron: "Necesitamos comenzar por proveer
un museo de arte contemporáneo
en Louisville. Ese es nuestro objetivo principal".
Entonces, en vez de ser desarrolladores inmobiliarios que ven una oportunidad
de hacer dinero, ellos se consideraron catalizadores
en el centro de su ciudad.
Y el hecho de que quisieran apoyar
el museo de arte contemporáneo constituía su pro forma,
de modo que trabajaron al revés.
Y esa pro forma nos llevó
a un edificio de usos múltiples que era muy grande
para respaldar sus aspiraciones artísticas
pero también abrió oportunidades para que el propio arte
colabore, interactúe con los espacios comerciales
en los que, cada vez más, los artistas querían trabajar.
Y también nos hacía pensar en la manera de conseguir
al mismo tiempo un edificio simple
y una especie creíble de subestructura.
Bien, ahora voy a-- este es el perfil de la ciudad de Louisville --
y les voy a mostrar
varias restricciones que nos llevan al proyecto.
Primero, las restricciones físicas. En realidad teníamos que operar
en tres sitios independientes,
todos mucho, mucho más pequeños que el tamaño del edificio.
Teníamos que operar al lado del nuevo centro Mohamed Alí,
y respetarlo.
Teníamos que operar en el área inundable de 100 años.
Ahora, esta área se inunda tres o cuatro veces al año,
y hay un dique detrás de nuestro sitio
similar al que se rompió en Nueva Orleáns.
Teníamos que operar detrás del corredor I-64,
una calle que atraviesa estos sitios separados.
Entonces éstas -- comenzamos a construir una especie de
pesadilla de restricciones en una bañera.
Debajo de la bañera están
las líneas troncales de electricidad de la ciudad.
Y hay un corredor peatonal que ellos querían que agregásemos
que conectaría una serie de edificios culturales
y un corredor panorámico -- porque este es el distrito histórico --
que no querían obstruir con el nuevo edificio.
(Risas)
Y vamos a agregar cerca de 102 mil metros cuadrados.
Y si siguiéramos el método tradicional, esos 102 mil metros cuadrados --
estos son programas diferentes -- el método consistiría en identificar
los elementos públicos, ubicarlos en sitios,
y tendríamos una situación terrible:
algo público en medio de una bañera que se inunda.
Y luego deberíamos dimensionar los otros elementos --
los distintos elementos comerciales:
hoteles, residencias de lujo, oficinas, etc.
y arrojarlos arriba. Y crearíamos algo
que no sería viable.
De hecho -- lo saben – esto se llama el edificio Time Warner.
(Risas)
Entonces nuestra estrategia fue muy simple.
Simplemente elevar todo el bloque,
rotar alguno de los elementos, reposicionarlos,
para que tengan vistas apropiadas y relaciones con el centro de la ciudad,
hacer conexiones de circulación y desviar la calle.
Ese es el concepto básico
y ahora les voy a mostrar adónde nos lleva.
OK, parece un gesto muy formal, deliberado,
pero algo completamente derivado de las restricciones.
Y cuando lo mostramos por primera vez, hubo nerviosismo
en el sentido que se trataba de arquitectos haciendo una declaración,
y no de arquitectos que tratan de resolver
una serie de problemas.
Ahora, dentro de esa zona céntrica, como dije,
tenemos la posibilidad de mezclar una serie de cosas.
Aquí pueden ver que estos
rayos X las torres
están totalmente orientadas al desarrollador inmobiliario. Ellos nos dieron las dimensiones, los tamaños, etc.
y nosotros nos focalizamos en los componentes públicos --
los vestíbulos, los bares,
todo lo que los distintos elementos comerciales tendrían
y los combinamos en el centro, en una especie de mapa del subterráneo,
en la zona de transferencia que también incluiría el museo de arte contemporáneo.
Entonces surge una situación como esta,
donde hay artistas que pueden operar dentro
de un espacio de arte que tiene una vista increíble en el piso 22
pero que también tiene proximidad que el curador
puede abrir o cerrar.
Permite que la gente que hace ejercicios en bicicleta
sea vista o vea el arte, etc.
También significa que si el artista quiere apropiarse de algo, como una piscina,
puede exhibir en la piscina,
de modo que no están forzados a trabajar siempre dentro de los confines
del espacio de la galería de arte contemporáneo.
Bien, ¿cómo construir esto?
Muy simple: es una silla.
Entonces, comenzamos construyendo el núcleo.
A medida que construimos el núcleo construimos el museo de arte contemporáneo a nivel.
Eso nos permitió lograr una increíble eficiencia y eficacia de costos.
Este no es un edificio de alto presupuesto.
En el momento en que el núcleo llega al nivel medio
terminamos el museo de arte, le colocamos todo el equipamiento mecánico,
y luego lo levantamos con un gato hidráulico.
Esta es la manera en que se construyen los inmensos hangares,
por ejemplo, los que se construyeron para el A380.
Cuando se termina el núcleo,
obtenemos algo como esto.
Ahora sólo tengo cerca de 30 segundos así que quiero comenzar
una animación y voy a concluir con eso.
(Aplausos)
Chris me pidió que agregue
que el teatro está en construcción y
que este proyecto comenzará a construirse aproximadamente dentro de un año
y finalizará en 2010.